nos condoléances pour votre grand père
j'avais plus que lui ton grand père ne
faisait jamais rien comme tout le monde
je suis une nouvelle copie c'est une
louve vient souvent me voir
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais
agent simpson et richardson il s'est
passé quelque chose dirige
cet avion qui s'est écrasé c'est
terrible l'avion transportait un
lionceau d'estimer un cirque on doit le
retrouver
tu vas jamais le croire d'abord il ya un
louveteau un lionceau et bouchons que
jusque chez kia c'est une copine de
grand-père quoi
séparables
la louve est parvenu je vais devoir
m'occuper d'eux
vous n'avez aucun droit sur ces bêtes
oh
rendez moi mon lyon je vous promets
qu'ils vous arrivera rien
comment tu t'en occupes râle quand ils
seront adultes [ __ ] les protéger
ils s'adorent
récupérer mon lyon d'une manière ou
d'une autre
afin nous et ont
faim nous et on